game with Chris you know it's
predominantly in camera he's he's very
reluctant to use CGI unless entirely
essential
um so that's why I think his films are
so visceral and so such that
um such kind of honesty to them and
because most of the stuff you're seeing
actually happened
Charles you remember
that was my first day on Sat actually I
remember that was my first day on
Saturday remember the water in the glass
tilts like that
feel that
you've actually been trained for this Mr
Fisher pay attention to the strangeness
of the weather in order to achieve that
effect they had built to hold a whole
bar
was on a gimbal that just went
so it was again no cgis they built this
huge huge set and we came on and did the
scene and then this set just tilted as
stuff went crazy